je préfère qu'on reste amis c'est un des
films français à la fiche dans les
salles à partir d'aujourd'hui une
comédie l'oeuvre d'un duo de
réalisateurs qui s'appuie sur un tandem
d'acteurs que tout oppose
gérard depardieu et jean paul rouve dans
un rôle inédit
dominique poncet examen la vie c'est
comme une partie poker tu vois on a
distribué les mauvaises cartes qu'est ce
qu'on fait quand on n'a pas de jeu un
angle frondeuse au cinéma on n'avait
encore jamais vu jean-paul rouve dans un
rôle comme celui là faut metinides
angoisses et complexé et donc maladroit
à vous fendre le coeur frappé à la bonne
porte monsieur mandelbaum votre pseudo
sera 2009
quelle idée c'est justement parce qu'ils
avaient envie de surprendre son monde
que l'ex robin des bois a accepté
d'emblée ce personnage est aussi parce
que dans le film il allait faire tandem
avec gérard depardieu dans un rôle
totalement opposé au sien
je suis blanc cette histoire d'amitié
utilisent les mêmes codes qu'une
histoire d'amour et c'est ça une vraie
histoire d'amitié c'est à dire qui a le
coup de foudre
le la séparation la jalousie les
retrouvailles
il n'y a pas de sexe c'est la seule
différence et j'aimais bien cette façon
de traiter l'amitié qui est très lady
[ __ ] yens
mais la ventura d'autres après
3 après une blague
les réalisateurs comme moi on a grandi
avec
on a grandi avec avec le cinéma français
des années 70 avec les yves robert avec
les films de webber et que les films
écrits par dabadie tout ce cinéma là
populaire français de qualité et pierre
on a grandi que gérard depardieu et l'on
se retrouve à tourner que gérard
depardieu les jeux these jadis sang
froid d'un tdp lis pas si tu es athée
lectrices t'es mort excusez moi monsieur
n'est plus de 1000 pop c'est normal
c'est normal on est en rupture de stock
c'est bizarre non pourquoi tout le monde
s'adressent à toi 11 normales c'est
comme ça depuis toujours j'ai l'habitude
et je veux qu'on entend par exemple dans
mon dernier boulot j'avais quitté la
boîte depuis un an et demi on continue à
me payer ah bon et pourquoi s'est pas
rendu compte que j'étais parti le
tournage dit encore jean paul rouve a
été ponctuée de fous rires sur la
pellicule cela se ressent cette comédie
sentimentale dégage une vraie gaieté je
sais très bien que j'ai assez peu de
points communs avec deux idées